welcome to the session on react native
versus flutter in this session we would
look at identifying some of the
differences between the react native and
flutter frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the UI aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends in terms of the industry
adoption for both these platforms the
core objective of the session would be
that at the end you should be able to
decide and make an informed decision as
to which framework is the best among
those available let's start from a
language perspective now if you look at
react react is basically completely
written and built in JavaScript using
the react is EBI on the other hand if
you look at flutter it is basically
written in a very new language called as
dart and we do not have too many
developers that are skilled on dart
however every browser and every platform
be shipped with an inbuilt JavaScript
execution environment that makes
JavaScript platform the language of
choice for developers so every browser
today or every browser manufacturer
would have it build support for
executing JavaScript programs similarly
most popular platforms mobility
platforms like Android and iOS have
default support for executing JavaScript
programs and that's the reason when you
compare this with flutter flutter uses
dart which is predominantly a newer
language and you really do not have too
many developers who are skilled
so that really is the selling point and
the USB off react native because when
you work with react native you really do
not have to relearn a lot you don't have
a sharp learning curve most of the
JavaScript developers who are working
with mean stack already works with HTML
CSS and dhtml can easily align to this
that is we have discussed is pretty new
in the industry and would not have that
much of penetration in the developer
community from a UI perspective when you
talk about react native it's based
pretty much on native components for the
Android in the iOS platform and
fluttered on the other hand uses a very
proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement
third-party widgets and UI frameworks as
well now this is very what allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo UI or a set of
generic controls or any other
third-party UI framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the UI components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically is
built and uses JavaScript out of the box
and that's the reason when you want to
write any code in JavaScript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you
are using flutter on the other hand
flutter does not need any kind of bridge
so there's no concept of you write
letter code and then it uses a bridge to
go and connect to the native set of
components to interact with and this is
what really impacts the speed and the
performance aspect of developing and
executing applications between both
these frameworks because if you look at
react the speed of development is a
little bit slower when you compare that
with flutter and that's because it has
an intermediate Play
that it has to communicate with an every
layer of additional communication and
computation that you put in between two
tiers
you know application that you build
obviously would have a performance
impact from a documentation perspective
if we were to compare clutter typically
has a very well-defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on the react native because it react
native it actually since react native is
an open ecosystem it allows you to
implement third-party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and
plug-in play and that's the reason the
documentation also is not very strong
well-organized and impactful and that's
the reason most developers who find it a
little challenging to go through the
react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always an even working with platforms
and that should be a crucial
decision-maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you're obviously Google
will come into the community to go and
find out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter be relatively a new
entrant into the market it does not have
a lot of developer penetration and
that's a reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react need
to be there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason it's pretty popular among
developers also since it uses JavaScript
it's a natural transition and a
progression path for those who are
working with html5 CSS building web
applications or happy building hybrid
mobile apps find it very easy to migrate
to this because flutter requires you to
learn a new programming language which
is start and that is one more reason why
the popularity of this is much much
better on the react native front as
compared to flutter again if you look at
Google Trends
you actually look at both of the lines
here the red line indicating flutter it
started on a very positive note and then
there was a plateau and then suddenly a
spy react native has been much more
steady in terms of its growth
and ultimately if you look at it now
both of them seem to be trending at par
with each other so that the munities
support as we were speaking up about if
you look at Stack Overflow which is one
of the most popular websites to go for
any kind of developer trends and
movements and for Q&A that most
developers would have you can actually
look at the number of questions here and
also the active is part of github as
it's open source it was released in 2015
and it's because of the huge community
support that it becomes easier to
implement this you have a lot of
confidence as a developer when you start
building on this stack because if you're
stuck somewhere you will have lot of
help available on the way on the other
hand if you compare that with splatter
you could look at the question count
here on Stack Overflow and this being a
new entrant in the market it has a
smaller footprint on the community
aspect but of course that gives
increasing every day again from a react
native perspective and you talk about
stability in terms of stable releases
there again you would see that we had
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tends or something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if we would
need to make a decision in terms of our
careers the technology that we are
learning what is the growth aspect what
is the industry adoption and how we
could really move ahead on our career
graphs in terms of the opportunities
public the chirp market etc so again
getting back to Stack Overflow which is
the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in IT sphere and all
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in two thousand
nineteen sixty two point five percent of
developers seem to have shown interest
in react native as compared to a
marginal rise of sixty five point four
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better of course that could be due
to the time frames that both these
technologies have been around reactors
been around for quite a while and hence
the job prospects are much better a lot
of organized
it's implementing this clutters been a
new entrant and hence a slightly fewer
opportunities as if the penetration
still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and from a
developer skills perspective so these
are some of the big names that are using
react native in their implementations
right from Facebook to Pinterest to
week's sky Tesla in star Bloomberg you
can actually look at the implementation
of cross industry which is absolutely
crucial when you're learning something
new because when you want to join a
large logo obviously if there are a lot
of locals using this that enhances the
credibility of your to your learning
puts a justification to why you would
want to learn this technology better on
the other hand associated with big names
like Google's Sonos Alibaba the largest
retailer out there from a confusion
perspective if we were to conclude on
what we've discussed from a language
perspective obviously we said react is
much more popular since it is a natural
progression for developers to work on
javascript and move to this as compared
to tart which is relatively a new
language from a UI perspective the
open-source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party UI platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a boost
ecosystem it depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not rot any longer required
in flutter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
it between the up documentation much
much better in flutter because it's a
closed ecosystem and they can control
what you can use react native be
open-ended it really has a lot of
third-party division you can do and
hence the documentation is not really
well organized the popularity
perspective react native much more
popular among html5 css3 mod means that
developers since it's all JavaScript
flutter needs you to learn new skills
and you need to spend additional time
for that from a community support react
native has been there for a longer time
as compared to flutter and hence
as a stronger community support as
compared to flatter and that translates
into better job prospects in the
industry for react native as compared to
flutter so if we were to give it a score
react scores much better with a total
score of five leaving flutter with a
total score of two so I hope we were
able to understand the differences
between the react native and flutter and
this will help you make better decisions
with planning your career and deciding
which technology you should latch on to
thanks so much for connecting to the
symphony on channel do like us to
subscribe to click on the bell icon so
you are notified what you contend that
we put out and do leave comments for us
so that we can keep adding a tender in
receive thank you hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos turner up and get
certified click here